foreign
happy one year anniversary Peter thanks
[Music]
thank you
all right so Tim you've been working on
documentation yeah been remaking our
website share those beautiful animations
again
do you have a estimated
this stuff
oh it's probably going to be good to go
with the release I think with the
release yeah speaking of which one's not
coming
uh all right you know would you like to
blow out the candle
um I can try I don't think it's gonna
necessarily work though well those those
sweets
oh almost Peter one more time
well done you did it
gravity has a bit broken because he was
born that way but it blew out into that
I mean it goes around the planet what
kind of cake is it though
it's an orange cake because the studio
camera can see
[Music]
okay so we have a bug here that Tim
wants me to fix and I know nothing about
it and we thought it would be fun for
the devlog to show
how I go about fixing a bug in Hazel so
here's the bug in jira with dark mode on
changes to materials aren't always
updating the scene okay so I guess you
can explain what the bug is uh so
sometimes when you'd open the material
editor and make a change for the
material
um that change wouldn't be observed in
the scene so in the screenshot here you
can see that the emission is zero and
that is clearly a very emissive material
so that's not being updated like live
um and that's you've double clicked on
like a material in the content browser I
think I even opened it from uh from the
mesh but yeah oh yeah either either or
it doesn't really matter and so Peter's
actually detailed some of his findings
in this bug in the comments below the
instance of the material asset changes
after we've edited or closed it
the only reason this is an issue is
because the mesh components references
material that's by instance not by
handle
most likely there's a bug with the
reference counting system uh I doubt it
I like how this is like Peter's devlog
it's just like yep I've opened it guys I
can reproduce it
okay I guess let's just like make it
happen because I don't really like to
read what you guys say so
um let's open up was that that was just
like something you created that little
sandbox example yeah it can be easily
recreated okay can you reproduce it yeah
and then we find this material which is
a green emission
and so now it should work right yeah I
close it and now it's not going to get
up there you can see that
yeah and is it like oh well I just
crashed
that's I haven't seen that happen Okay
and there's more come with Peter tried
to blame my reference counting system
can you believe that Tim is that not
just stirring up some drama
oh yeah how could Peter
yeah because like of course the
reference counting system works
perfectly for all the games we've
shipped and then suddenly when editing
materials it just breaks
likely and now see now it doesn't cross
no it doesn't crash the crash is like
I've never seen this is clearly wrong
like whatever this material can I I
can't add the calories nothing nothing
changes so the way it works you now have
to reassign it to the mesh and then the
changes will take effect
okay so somehow
oh
or as Peter said restart the editor but
this is yeah yeah on reciting the editor
works yeah well according to Peter I
haven't actually tested that but yeah
yeah resetting the material like that
works yeah so once that's done it will
do need serialize and it means it will
it should write its disk
I believe
so if we
drag that when we finish dragging
it will try and serialize that to the
material asset which is yeah it looks
like that same handle
with an emission value of what it should
be
and I guess we write that out to the
file okay so it looks like the file gets
its value saved correctly
yeah 1.2
okay so now then what that means is that
somehow I think the functionality what
we've determined is the functionality of
this and this seems to be good it looks
like somehow whatever this static mesh
is holding in the material table it
doesn't seem to be linked to this
anymore for whatever reason
um
I think I might know why
if we look at
so basically the way that this works is
that in the components we have obviously
a static mesh component
which has a material table
and the material table
is basically just like a map of material
index to material assets material asset
is what we just saw
uh and so what happens is when it has to
render that it will basically just look
up that material table and ask it do you
have a material uh index like zero
um and if it does then
it will use that so the way that happens
is
well I guess we can you look at scene
renderer but it's probably in Falcon
renderer
so if I submit a static mesh
um see that gets submitted with a
material table I guess we should just
verify that it's actually being
submitted with the correct material
table but I'm sure it is
um yes the static mesh component
material table that gets submitted into
here we have a material table and you
can see that what it does is it asks to
see if it has a material at the given
index so what we can do here if we
wanted to is we could basically just
make sure that that material asset
actually had that correct value when
it's submitted for rendering so to test
that out what I would do is we'll launch
in debug mode and I'm going to make a
new scene that just has that single
um
that basically just has that single uh
you know cylinder or whatever we make
with one material just so that that way
it's easier to debug because obviously
in the current scene it's submitting
like 30 meshes and so it's going to be
really hard for us to find the one we're
looking for
um so let's look at that green emission
material again
which is now that color
that's fine let's make that grain again
okay so that works right I might just
reduce this
all right so that still works
um but if I close it and reopen it
and let's make this red so that doesn't
work
uh okay so now what I want to do then is
what seems to have happened is if we try
and random now and we know that's the
only thing being random so if I put a
breakpoint here so we can look at them
okay let's just see if it finds the
material right so
um material table has material at index
zero I'm guessing yeah that definitely
has a material at index zero um what I'm
looking for is the node now I kind of
want to look at the buffer I guess
which is mildly annoying but it's going
to tell me whether or not I've made it
red that's why I changed it from green
to Red because that would be easy to see
so if I look at the uniform storage
buffer which is this guy over here
um so material zero second
okay
but the problem is again the layout is
gonna matter but it should just be if I
go to PBR it's static
and we look at that so I'll bet a color
should actually be the first one okay so
look at that what does that look like to
you
uh well it's very green yes so it's
green it's that green material
so somehow it's not well we kind of knew
that because we're seeing it we're
seeing it and if it's seeing and then
it's probably being submitted to the
renderer so somehow what that means is
that
they might have to be different
materials but something happens on
material panel close that makes a loose
reference
I don't think it loses reference I just
think that the material asset
I think what happens is uh but that
doesn't make sense either does it what
I'm thinking is that potentially it
serialized it it serializes the value
correctly and that's why we see uh this
you know that being
red yes that part works
um
but it just doesn't like that's not the
one that it uses for rendering for
whatever reason like I just think it
never reads it back from the disc or
something like that yeah but it
shouldn't have to because I'm pretty
sure like what we're doing is we should
be access we should be editing editing
the material that is within the material
asset
and the material asset that we have
should be the exact same material asset
that is coming from that material table
because we've said it but hang on but
does that make sense
maybe that doesn't make sense
no but it was the first time it works
the first time so I think it's literally
it's closing that panel does something
no well closing that panel actually I
don't think closing that panel
it did do something yeah it's closing
that panel doesn't do anything it just
releases the reference that is being
held here
which is not that no that's the wrong
thing
but yeah you can see material asset gets
set to null so it just releases the
reference and in here it's setting it it
setting it to an asset that's passed in
here which again should be the correct
material asset that we're rendering and
then we also serialize it and it is
serialized correctly
okay here's the next step then if we
Chuck a breakpoint in here
when I open this
like it obviously has to be a different
one right because I believe when I open
it
it's red it's red yeah so it opens the
correct one but it doesn't work yeah
correct no it's like it's it's made yeah
it's like Peter was saying I guess it's
like it's made a separate instance of it
yeah but how unless that's been
explicitly copied which could have
happened
so what happens when we um but it's
already been assigned
oh how did that end up happening okay I
just want to mention though that
initially like I don't like this design
because
I don't think we should be passing
around refs of assets I think that we
should be passing around as it handles
because first of all this is so much
yeah I know it because possibly before
asset handles were a thing maybe really
well I don't know but the thing is we
shouldn't do that like and we don't do
that everywhere because if you look at
components right most of these things
are asset handles
um it's just that the material table
internally the material Table stores
actual material assets yeah
um which again shouldn't be a problem
because as long as you
I know what it is
I think I know what it is
I think what happens is when the
material changes on disk
and maybe when you press close or
whatever it probably loads it from disk
again
and by doing so
it obviously refresh it recreates it but
this guy is the old one
[Music]
yeah so this is like the old one before
it's serialized or whatever you were
initially editing that
by then I think when you load it it's
like it doesn't it must do an on reload
we can actually check though
we can check this Theory really easily
um because
the asset manager
I don't know exactly where this would be
would probably have to reload that asset
so import asset let's do import asset
is would that be it is that the thing
that does the right thing no what am I
I'm looking for asset importer
so asset importer try load data yeah
this guy
so if this runs when I double click on
this
widgets
maybe it does doesn't but let's modify
it ah
it does as soon as you modified it runs
because it loads it again so where does
that happen on file system changed
reload data apparently and see what it
does it imp it like literally will
um import a brand new asset it'll still
it should it'll still have the same
asset handle but it's replaced this with
another one so now that reference that
you had in the material table is
completely it doesn't exist anymore it's
an old version of the same asset
but why is the material turbo not
updated or is this not how we should do
it well no it's just the material table
is not updated because it has no idea
that the assets haven't been Reloaded
well yeah basically what you do is you
have an actual ref of an asset so you
have an actual physical asset that
you've set onto the onto the material
table and then elsewhere what happens if
you modify the asset that's fine because
the data is the same it's the same
pointer to the same block of memory but
if you decide to reload the asset
entirely you're replacing the actual
object so now you can't possibly like
you know automatically get the new copy
yeah you know what I mean it's not yeah
and so the solution here really and I
could patch this up but the real
solution here would be to just
um
where's that material table the real
solution here inside material asset is
we just should never be storing material
assets like this should just be an asset
handle
uh and that's it so let's replace that
quickly that shouldn't really be too
difficult
of a change but that that's why because
what will happen now is as soon as we
need this we reach for yeah we reach for
the asset manager and be like hey man
what is this asset and of course it's
going to provide us with the correct one
yeah because this is the identifying
like way we identify it so let's do
asset hand so I'm just patching this up
to just be asset handle everywhere and
that's the beauty of asset handles oh we
might need to make the copying work
differently or maybe not because yeah
that's the same
so basically just to find a replace kind
of which is control F7 that I might just
do release mode here
I'm not about to run it though I need to
do a lot of a lot more changing let's
just shift F7 and see where it breaks
that's just gonna show us
so far
you can see they come up early I don't
know
seeing hierarchy panel okay so as soon
as we want to get this
um and do we check to see if that's null
though no not really we're sure that it
has one so at this point then it's still
compiling I think
um Okay so
basically we can just do get asset
material asset yeah because we have
another material asset handle here so
that's why I'm being specific with my
words here I could just shove that in
here as well I don't know I like to
write code out a bit more but both
because that way can debug it easier and
of course the compiler is gonna
makes sense of that anyway so it doesn't
matter so I'll work with this file so
now control F7 yeah I know I just like
to every every RI fixer basically
um make sure uh yeah do that so material
here material table get material so this
itself is a handle which is funny which
is funny because what that means now is
that when we get this first of all it
shouldn't be const Auto and second of
all that can actually be the thing we
return
because it's going to be zero if it's
not there
um well actually let's look at this so
get material okay so if I no but it has
to so this is weird as well because this
function asserts if it doesn't have a
material whereas here we're checking to
see if material we return is a null
which is very weird
yeah you should ask it does it have a
material first externally so but but
anyway regardless we can just do get
material and remove that whole block see
again here we're trying to get the
handle but it already is a handle
so this actually almost simplifies
things because again the rest of the
engine mostly uses handles uh I don't
know exactly why this isn't like that
okay so here we are setting the material
asset by actually dropping one on so we
just need to basically ask it for its
handle instead of setting it directly
because set material actually let me
just double check that but I'm pretty
sure set material has to take in an
asset handle as well
I didn't screw that up okay and last one
is here as well
okay that's that file done
you
yeah this is gonna take a while
could fast forward through this the
devlog that might be fun people to watch
[Music]
okay this is interesting so this is a
material table that we create when we
create a mesh so if we now want to do
that what that would do funnily enough
is it would actually create a new
material asset
um because we're creating a mesh from
mesh Source now is that really what we
want to do here oh I guess so yeah
because we're instantiating it so in
this case it's fine for us to do that
but we need to tell the asset manager
about it it's kind of scary that we
weren't before because that is almost
like a lost asset so we actually have to
do asset manager
um
I guess it would be a create yeah create
memory only asset um of type material
asset because that's kind of what we're
doing here
by the way I've I've seen this in the
code what is memory only asset what does
that mean it's something that isn't on
disk so something that's going to die
when you shut down yes like it just
doesn't exist on disk and what's the
alternative called just create uh uh you
can't decree asset I think it's um
um
um I don't even know
might be in the editor asset manager
there definitely is yeah create new
asset but you have to go through that's
not a generic thing because that's
editor specific yeah because the runtime
can't do that but the runtime can create
memory only
um yeah so we just do that pass that in
right yeah but we have to actually do
that in the for Loop
uh yeah and so what that does is that
gives us back an asset handle and that
handle is what we shove into
here like that so that's what that
becomes a little bit more complicated
than the other fixes
like by the way what is a static cost
it's the same as a c style cast but it
just like I say about this way of doing
it yeah
um yeah oh because it's a size T here
because it's size but here it's number
of materials that's why yeah I don't
like doing this just because I think it
adds a lot more code for no reason so I
prefer doing this and the community will
hate me for it but that's just how I
roll
um and there's no there's no runtime
difference at all
it's just the static cost um
like people say that you can kind of
search for it but it's like
well if you search for static cost in
your code base it'll come up but like
I've never had to in all my years I've
never had to do that once yeah so I
prefer and there's no performance
difference you say yeah it does the same
thing composite of the same code
absolutely yeah there are different
styles like this reinterpret cast
there's const cost there's Dynamic cast
and some of them do slightly different
things
um but static costs just is the same you
can use data cost in all places and this
is called implicit cost this is called a
c style cast implicit costing is when
you don't need a cost oh that's so it
implicitly converts I to yeah
um okay so material table has material
so that's fine but why is it not getting
oh no because material table itself
needs to be retrieved differently oh no
no okay so it's showing up here but the
error is probably here so what that
actually should do is give us a we need
to kind of divide this into two parts
um so let's do
so there's either ah but they're both
material tables yeah okay so
asset handle material handle
becomes one of those two and then we do
equals asset manager get assets so one
thing to be aware of is we are involving
the asset manager now in the renderer
which I don't know if I would do that
um like I like that is a
thing to think about because one might
argue that by the time you get down to
Falcon code like this you should already
have all of your assets kind of realized
meaning like they're already concrete
types not just like
so this is like I might add like a
little to do here or just a little note
to myself just so that I'm aware that
uh this is a bit this needs maybe some
design so I'll do a note uh probably at
this stage which basically all that
means is that we have to uh construct a
material table of actually ready
materials uh outside of this function
but the other thing to consider is this
runs on the render thread because it's
inside a render us a bit and so uh that
could also potentially be an issue and
that's part of the reason why we don't
really like to do this because the asset
manager actually isn't thread safe
um so we might yeah like I'll think
about this this might actually need
better design I don't think this is
great to do
because if we're modifying the asset
manager elsewhere while accessing it
here
that could have like some kind of weird
race condition
um and uh yeah with it for here it's
fine because it's on the main thread yep
and unfortunately this is the type of
bug that because we don't run the editor
multi-threaded this is the kind of bug
you'd only see in the runtime which is
kind of not great
um all right so let's do asset handle
[Music]
working on Hazel today
yeah that's uh rare for me um all right
where's my beautiful scene
do you think this will work
yeah I think so I did I didn't I think I
think we might crash first off really uh
and if we don't it will win yeah
gray intermission is red beautiful
that's what I want okay so uh that works
plan and we were expecting that to work
because I worked before yeah
that works no cool no wait okay so and
then what do we do we close it we open
it and it keeps working so that's fixed
right yep
say it doesn't it what's interesting is
that because of the way we do it this
used to happen before as well but it
doesn't update live while you do this
yeah you have to let go
which is a bit annoying because
otherwise that kind of sucks that you
can't see it until you let go yeah no
that that is actually really annoying
um yeah cool
I guess that's fixed
yeah yep you want to play with it or are
you happy no no I'm happy
about it